now to the double murder trial of Alex
Murdoch where we're told the prosecution
could rest its case later this week the
disgraced South Carolina lawyer denies
charges that he killed his wife and his
son as Nikki Batiste reports jurors
heard from a close family member for the
first time yesterday
it wasn't perfect
but Maggie was happy on the stand Marion
Proctor described her sister's marriage
to Alec murdaugh Proctor told jurors
that in the days after her sister Maggie
and nephew Paul were murdered her
brother-in-law Alex murdal seemed more
focused on a 2019 bow crash involving
Paul in which 19 year old Mallory Beach
was killed he said that
um
number one
number one goal was clearing Paul's name
and I thought that was so strange
because my number one goal was to find
out who killed my sister and pop Maggie
and Paul murdaugh were shot to death
near the family's dog kennel at Moselle
the family is sprawling hunting a state
in South Carolina on Monday newly
released body cam footage was played for
jurors showing an emotional and
distraught Murda on the night of the
murders it's bad to take the pulses then
Murdoch offers his own reasoning as to
why someone would murder his family my
son was in a boat wreck a few months
back he's been getting threats most of
it's been benign stuff we didn't take
Serious okay
um you know he he's been getting like
punched
um I know there's somebody I know that's
what it is and on Tuesday Proctor
testified that hours before her sister
was killed Alex asked Maggie to return
home from the family's beach house you
encouraged her to go to Mosa
I did
was that the last time you talked to him
yes for CBS mornings Nikki Batiste